hello everyone and welcome to another
very nice game from the Linares
Tournament of 2005. it is a Gary
kasparov's last tournament as an active
player and here's a very nice game
against the Paco Vallejo
um a very very sharp tactical game uh
where uh it seems like it almost seems
like it will end in a draw but that is
uh very far from the actual truth uh now
uh I'm gonna show a couple more games
from this tournament there are very
interesting games that were played here
even though there were uh there was an
exceptional amount of draws like so many
draws like Anand Drew nine games um
Peter lake or Drew are out of the 12
games he played he drew all 12 I mean
it's um incredible how many draws there
were but the games that were not draws
were very cool so this is one of the the
games is from round three uh let's check
it out and if you haven't seen my
previous video do check it out and
especially the beginning of it because
there is now a repository where you can
search all of my video because if you're
interested in for example show me all
the videos that I've made that Magnus
Carlsen played you can now do that you
can also search by opening you can also
search by the result of the game you can
search by the actual moves that were
played I will be the first link in the
description below so do check it out if
that is something that will help you out
now getting uh into the game uh Paco
with the white pieces opens with Knight
to F3 he goes for the ready opening with
D5 by Kasparov with D4 E6 sorry about
that
uh and at Pawn to C4 and here usually
you will see Knight to F6 this is a
standard reply but here D captures and
C4 casparov accepts the Queen's Gambit
this is the Rosenthal variation of the
Queen's Gambit accepted we have Pawn to
E4 now uh preparing Bishop captures on
C4 and because power defends the pawn
pawn to B5 we have Pawn to A4 uh
challenges the B5 pawn and C6 so nothing
new here even for for that uh era uh a
cap or C captures and pawn to B3
continuing to challenge the advanced
Pawn structure Bishop to B7 goes after
the E4 pawn and now B uh captures on C4
we have the bishop captures and E4 you
know you have you could consider a
couple of options here the the top moves
uh were Knight B to D2 and the C
captures and B5 uh Paco goes for B
captures a c captures on B5 which
creates uh a lot of pressure against
blacks Queen side like uh you have to
keep in mind that the B6 square if the
queen moves like I move like B6 could be
deadly uh so Knight to F6 now Bishop to
E2 and the bishop to E7 both players
Castle castles castles Knight to C3 uh
Paco goes after d for uh Bishop Bishop
back to B7 and now uh there are a couple
of games that reach this exact same
position for example even in 1996
vishwanathan Ananda defeated Anatoly
karpov here with Knight to E5 and there
are a couple of other games where
Knights the E5 was played but but
um uh Paco plays uh Bishop to F4 and it
is now as of move 13 that this position
has never been reached again and in 2005
it was a completely new move uh and
Kasparov now has to decide how to
continue the game thus he just continue
development Knight b37 does he try
something like A5 also seems nice you
either get a pass Pawn or you force
trades here but he doesn't he actually
goes for Bishop to B4 it comes with an
idea uh he wants the captain C3 in and
put his Knight on D5 and this will be a
beautiful Square for this Knight
so uh you like if Queen to B3 you defend
the Knight then Kasparov does exactly
that so Knight to A4 not allowing this
and now Knight B to D7 uh cause power
continues development also keeps Anand
that C5 Square he does not want this
Knight to get the C5 that that will be a
very nasty Steed there so Queen to B3 uh
putting pressure on the bishop and now
Knight to D5 defending on B4 and
attacking the bishop on F4 uh Bishop G5
attacks cause power's Queen 98 and now
Bishop back to E7 offering a trade
Bishop D2 declining the trade also
nicely controlling that Knight on D5 and
now Ponte A6 all of kaspar's pieces are
now developed it's time to open up the
rook and A8 uh Pawn to B6 and this is
where things uh get really really
interesting uh you you could just
capture B captures on A6 or you could
just put a rook on B1 or C1 and the
weight for for black the Capron B5 but
B6 is a move that um uh you you can't uh
not play I mean you you get a pass Pawn
on B6 and of course uh it's impossible
for black to capture if kasparo were to
play let's say Knight capture some B6
then just Bishop A5 and Kasparov can
resign he's gonna lose that Knight on B6
so instead after B6 with Bishop to C6 uh
and now Knight to E5 puts pressure on
the C6 Bishop Knight captures an E5 D
captures on E5 and now all made possible
by the undefended bishop on D2 Knight
captures on V6 now the bishop on D2 is
hanging so okay Knight captures and B6
casparov will also sacrifice The
Exchange here Queen captures on D2
Knight captures on A8 and now Queen
captures an A2 the Knight is still
attacked tonight back to C7 and queen
captures an E5 and now if you count um
now come to the pieces you can see that
Kasparov has
um uh he's done the exchange but he does
have two beautiful Bishops and he is up
two pawns so it's uh two pawns and an
exchange but the problem is the A6 spawn
will fall so it's uh more likely uh that
it's one Pawn so Queen to G3 offering a
queen trade and now Queen to F5 has part
of declines and only now Rook captures
on A6 grabbing that pawn so now because
part of his up one Pawn uh but the
bishop pair uh could be very scary if it
becomes fully operational so Rook to A7
uh uh sorry Bishop T4 first going for
Bishop to D3 to attack The Rook on F1
and rook and A6 so uh Rook to A7 putting
uh nasty pressure on that Bishop Bishop
to C5 now attacks the rook and also you
can see that now as part of the best
repair has become fully operational and
the way to continue this you you just
have to put the Rook back Rook 81 but
here uh Paco tried something very tricky
he tried to out calculate because part
of which is which is a you know an
impressive feat in itself if you are
able to accomplish it but the problem is
uh he he makes a mistake he he uh the
idea is nice and it works but if you if
you look far enough in the position then
you it seems like it doesn't work
because okay now everyone can see the
bishop characters and I have to check
will lose the Rook on A5 but of course
Paco Paco saw that there's a reason he
played it and the reason is very subtle
uh here Bishop captures an F2 check by
Kasparov Queen captures an F2 and now
Queen captures an A5 because spark just
grabs the rook and A5 uh attacks the
Knight on C7 but now Knight captures on
E6 and now you can see that uh the F
captures on E6 is impossible because of
just Queen captures and f8 Checkmate and
they're really aren't all that many
moves that kaspar can play however there
is one move that basically forces
resignation uh so feel free to pause the
video and try to spot this idea that uh
Buckle missed while I give you a couple
of seconds
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations on spotting the pawn
grab and for those of you who just want
to enjoy the show it is Bishop captures
and G2 that's the only move that wins
the game for black and this is the move
that Kasparov played and it was in this
position on move 29 that pacovejo
resigned to the game as there is nothing
more to be done here uh the problem is
if you don't play Bishop captures on G2
there is really not much else to try of
course we said this is impossible if you
dress up like Bishop D3 you offer a
trade uh then okay let's say Knight
captures Bishop captures and F1 Queen
captures an F1 check now let's say queen
C5 check the queen can capture on f8 or
or even the king you will have three
against two in a queen and pawn end game
this uh should not be enough for a win
however after this bishop captures and
G2 move you've snatched another pawn and
now you're just winning you're you're up
to pawns uh regardless of how uh White
plays this out it's just gonna be uh
you're going to be down two points
against Kasparov in an end game which is
of course completely unplayable problem
is if you capture with the King then
comes a nice Queen to D5 check and once
you move the king or block you're just
gonna recollect your queen characters
and E6 and you are up two pawns uh White
has a completely sharded position this
is completely winning for black and if
you don't capture with the King if you
capture with the queen not much
different even F characters than E60 you
could also give a check with the queen
and pick up the Knight with the queen
but even this is enough for a win still
it's two pawns not much to be done here
and you can't do nothing you can't
ignore uh or or even just going for a
trade like Knight captures an f8 even
this trade is possible but after Bishop
captures King captures and King captures
it's the exact same thing so you always
end up being down two pawns this is what
um Paco missed and a beautiful Victory
forecast part of with the black pieces
uh in this incredibly sharp line yeah
Bishop captures on G2 he resigned and
the custom Farm gets his first victory
of the tournament already in round three
so yeah that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it like I said if you haven't
seen the uh the the database do check it
out first link in the description below
I give a short explanation about it in
the previous videos so do check that out
as well and we are going to cover some
other nice games from this tournament as
you guys um uh enjoyed the the last one
so much uh so yeah that's the game I
hope you enjoyed it I would like to wish
a very happy birthday to Jules and I
would like to thank bocho Kenneth
Frazier debacles and CDs for trade for
your contribution to my channel thank
you a lot I really appreciate it as
usual you can check two of my previous
videos here thank you for watching and I
will see you soon continuing to check up
any wonderful suggestions uh and
whatever else happens in the Chess World
so thank you all I will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day